mit der Befragung der Bundesregierung
mit der Bundesministerin für Bildung und
Forschung die sich ja in diesen Tagen
nicht nur mit dem
fachkräfteeinwanderungsgesetz
beschäftigt hat sondern in diesen Tagen
auch schon gefordert hat modernere
Schulen mehr Lehrer hintergrund sind die
schwachen Leistungen von deutschen
Grundschülern die in diesen Tagen
ermittelt worden ist und da liegt
einiges im Argen und da hat die
Bundesministerin einiges gefordert also
wir kennen das Prozedere hier in der
Befragung der Bundesregierung es wird
ein paar einleitende Worte geben der
Bundesministerin die aus dem Kabinett
berichtet sie ist auch schon da sie
haben sich schon gesehen dass wir hier
also gleich alles pünktlich losgehen im
Hintergrund der Gong die Abgeordneten
erheben sich von ihren Plätzen so muss
das sein zu Beginn einer Sitzung und
dann wird gewartet auf die
Bundestagspräsidentin und die ist auch
schon auf dem Weg und die wird gleich
diese Sitzung hier eröffnen und dann
können wir sofort rein Experten in das
was an diesem Mittwochmittag wichtig ist
im Parlament
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich wünsche
allen einen schönen guten Tag die
Sitzung ist eröffnet
interfraktionell ist vereinbart worden
die Tagesordnung um die in der
zusatzpunkte-liste aufgeführten Punkte
zu erweitern von der Frist für den
Beginn der Beratung soll soweit
erforderlich abgewichen werden heute
folgt nach der Fragestunde auf Verlangen
der koalitionsfraktion eine Aktuelle
Stunde zu dem Thema Proteste in China
und die deutsche China-Politik am
Donnerstag ist vorgesehen im Anschluss
an Tagesordnungspunkt 7 den Antrag der
Fraktion der cdu/csu keine
erbschaftssteuererhöhung durch die
Hintertür mit einer debattenzeit von 68
Minuten aufzusetzen
Tagesordnungspunkt 8 und die weiteren
Punkte der cdu/csu-fraktion verschieben
sich entsprechend nach hinten wobei
Tagesordnungspunkt 8 nunmehr mit einer
debattenzeit von 39 Minuten und
Tagesordnungspunkt 14 mit einer
debattendauer von 26 Minuten beraten
werden sollen
nachsehen ohne Debatten Punkten findet
auch Verlangen der Fraktion der cdu/cs
sondern eine Aktuelle Stunde mit dem
Titel Pläne der Bundesregierung zur
schnelleren Einbürgerung statt
zudem ist vorgesehen Tagesordnungspunkt
37 Buchstabe i nach Tagesordnungspunkt
15 mit einer Beratungszeit von 39
Minuten aufzusetzen außerdem sollen die
Tagesordnungspunkte 16 und 20 sowie
Zusatzpunkt 5 abgesetzt werden
schließlich soll noch die Stellungnahme
des Bundesrates und die Gegenäußerung
der Bundesregierung zum Entwurf des
sanktionsdurchsetzungsgesetzes
zwei auf Drucksache
4.687 an die bereits den Gesetzentwurf
beratenden Ausschüsse überwiesen werden
ich sehe keinen Widerspruch dann ist das
so beschlossen ich rufe jetzt auf den
Tagesordnungspunkt eins Befragung der
Bundesregierung die Bundesregierung hat
mitgeteilt dass heute die
Bundesministerin vor Bildung und
Forschung Frau Bettina stark Watzinger
zur Verfügung steht Frau
Bundesministerin sie haben das Wort für
ihre einleitenden
Ausführung
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir hatten
gerade die Stellungnahme unsere
Stellungnahme zum nationalen
Bildungsbericht im Kabinett und wie
immer Licht und Schatten aber vor allen
Dingen ein Riesenauftrag an uns alle
unser Bildungssystem es braucht ein
Update bei der Forschung da stehen wir
besser da wir sind die größte
forschungsnation Europas dieses Niveau
müssen wir halten vor allem besser
werden bei Transfer und Innovation
gerade in Zeiten wie diesen bei denen in
denen so vieles ins Wanken gerät
Forschung und Bildung die Aufmerksamkeit
schenken die sie gerade jetzt verdient
das macht diese Bundesregierung Bildung
und Forschung haben bei uns Priorität
auch in der Krise und vor allen Dingen
ziehen wir wichtige Trennwänden in
dieser Zeit am Anfang dass die Schulen
offen bleiben und jetzt sollte das Gas
knapp werden dass sie Vorrang geliefert
werden für Klassenräume dass sie so warm
wie möglich sind und die Hochschulen und
wissenschaftlichen Einrichtungen sie
sind einbezogen in die Soforthilfe Gas
und bei der Gas- und strompreisbremse
für die außeruniversitäre Forschung gibt
es einen extra härtefallfonds damit
wissenschaftliche Arbeit gerade in
diesen Zeiten auch weitergeht wir haben
uns für die Studierenden stark gemacht
die hohen Energiekosten treffen sie
besonders hart Ergebnis 200 Euro
Einmalzahlung für 3,5 Millionen
Studierende und Fachschülerinnen und
Fachschüler
bafög-
und zwei das sind 230 und 345 Euro junge
Menschen dürfen nicht noch einmal zu
kurz kommen wie während der Pandemie das
ist eine der Trendwenden die wir
vollziehen wir nehmen die Belange der
jungen Menschen ernst
dafür steht auch die bafög-form der
erhöhte Fördersatz 8% können das sein
inklusive wohngeldzuschlag
wohnkostenzuschlag es können wieder mehr
Menschen vom Bafög profitieren auch
ältere bis zum Alter von 45 Jahren
erhalten ihn eine Trendwende wie
vereinbart und das ist erst der Anfang
dazu kommen Durchbrüche in den Bund
ländergesprächen bei der gemeinsamen
Wissenschaftskonferenz konnten wir
erreichen dass wir den
zukunftsvertragsstudium und Lehre sehr
wichtig für die Hochschulen dynamisieren
wir entwickeln das
Professorinnenprogramm weiter wir weiten
die exzellenzstrategie aus wir bündeln
unsere Kräfte in der Forschung unsere
Zukunftsstrategie sie befindet sich in
der Ressortabstimmung unsere Bilanz nach
einem Jahr es ist eine starke Bilanz
meine Damen und Herren
wir haben
wir haben auch einen Haushalt
vorgefunden den wir zum Teil erstmal
wieder auch solide und ehrlich machen
mussten und wir haben eine Trendwende
hier korrigiert nämlich die Trendwende
für ein Minus für Bildung und Forschung
wir haben daraus wieder ein Plus gemacht
drei Milliarden Euro mehr für Bildung
und Forschung in dieser
Legislaturperiode 3 Milliarden Euro mehr
für Zukunft und wir arbeiten zielgenau
die Riesenbaustelle bei der Bildung das
sind die ungleichen Bildungschancen und
deshalb kämpfen wir für das staatchancen
Programm es soll da ansetzen wo es am
nötigsten ist in Schulen mit vielen
Kindern und Jugendlichen die sozial
benachteiligt sind auch hier das Ziel
Trendwende nämlich das
aufstiegsversprechen Erneuern nur mit
bester Bildung hat jeder einzelne die
Chance nur mit bester Bildung bleibt
Deutschland erfolgreich möchte auch die
Exzellenzinitiative erwähnen berufliche
Bildung sie wird in der nächsten Woche
vorgestellt denn wir brauchen mehr junge
Menschen die in die berufliche
Ausbildung gehen damit sie die
Zukunftsfragen mit uns lösen und vor
allen Dingen auch die Technologien mit
uns entwickeln und verbauen wir brauchen
einen Umdenken in den Köpfen auch hier
brauchen wir eine Trendwende Richtung
Zukunft lassen wir noch sagen dass wir
natürlich mit Blick auf die großen
disruptionen Klimawandel digitaler
Wandel demografischer Wandel jeden
brauchen der mit anpackt und mehr
Optimismus Mut und Offenheit dass wir
diese zeitenwände auch zu Trendwende
machen und das kann eben Wissenschaften
und die viele Ideen die liegen in den
Schubladen der Hochschulen sie müssen
jetzt raus rein ins Leben das ist ein
Kernanliegen der Bundesregierung
deswegen die deutsche Agentur für
Transfer und Innovation mit der Dativ
schaffen wir eine Neuheit in der
Förderlandschaft und daneben die Sprint
die Agentur für sprunginnovationen die
sollen mehr Beinfreiheit erhalten denn
Patente von gestern sie sichern nicht
die Zukunft von morgen
technologieoffenheit ist das was uns
treibt in dieser Koalition offen sein
für wirklich Neues und das ist der
Markenkern eben auch in der Wissenschaft
und in der Wissenschaftspolitik frei
denken wir sind derzeit dran am Hochlauf
der Wasserstofftechnologie die Forschung
räumt die letzten Hürden aus und ich war
im Sommer in Greifswald habe mir
Wendelstein 7x angeschaut die
Fusionsforschung sie ist eine große
Chance für uns wenn uns der Durchbruch
hier gelingt dann haben wir die
Energiefrage ein großes Stück gelöst und
deswegen ist ganz klar keine Chance
ungenutzt lassen echte Trendwenden
brauchen echte technologieoffenheit ich
freue mich jetzt auf Ihre Fragen ich
freue mich jetzt auf die Diskussion mit
Ihnen meine Damen und Herren
vielen Dank wir beginnen die
regierungsbefragung zu den einleitenden
Ausführungen der Bundesministerin Frau
Bettina stark Watzinger und zum
Geschäftsbereich sowie zu den
vorangegangenen Kabinettssitzung und mit
allgemeinen Fragen das Wort hat zuerst
aus der cdu/csu-fraktion Thomas jazzomik
Frau Bundesministerin sie haben uns
heute nicht viel Neues erzählt und wir
haben erfahren aber in der letzten Zeit
das 23,8% der Kinder nach ifo Gutachten
keine Basiskompetenzen beim Abgang aus
der Schule haben schlimmer noch der IQB
Bildungsmonitor der sagt das sogar jedes
dritte Kind nicht richtig
Rechtschreibung beherrscht was wollen
Sie tun um das Problem zu lösen sie
haben zwei erfolgreiche Programme gerade
gestoppt aufholen nach Corona 2
Milliarden ist gestoppt sprach Kitas in
der frühkindlichen Bildung ist gestoppt
sie haben gesagt sie wollen das statt
chancenprogramm bringen doch wir sehen
jetzt aus ihrem Konzept das soll erst im
Kabinettsbeschluss in der ersten Hälfte
24 kommen was tun sie im Jahr 2023 um
den benachteiligten Kindern zu helfen
wann kommt ihr Konzept für das Stadt
chancen-programm wann beginnen die
ersten Schulen mit dem Startchancen
Programm und wie wollen sie den
Verteilungsmechanismus organisieren nach
Königsteiner Schlüssel oder nach bedürft
Frau Minister ja sehr geehrter Herr
Kollege ja zombeck sie sprechen ein
Thema an das nicht erst seit gestern
leider Realität in Deutschland ist die
Kompetenzen unserer Schülerinnen und
Schüler am Ende der Grundschule sie
singen seit 2011 und wir müssen hier
entgegensteuern es sind Lebenschancen es
ist aber auch natürlich es sind die
klugen Köpfe die wir für die Zukunft
brauchen und insofern haben wir gesehen
dass wir jetzt eine Trendwende einleiten
müssen indem wir gezielt dort fördern wo
die Förderung nicht stattfindet nämlich
das staatschancenprogramm sie haben das
aufholprogramm nach Corona erwähnt es
war gut in einer Krisensituation auch so
etwas auf den Weg zu bringen aber keiner
von uns weiß wirklich welchen Effekt das
Programm hatte und deswegen nehmen wir
auch das was die Wissenschaft und sagt
was auch die ständige wissenschaftliche
Kommission sagt der KMK nämlich dass wir
uns wissenschaftlich begleiten lassen
müssen dass wir auch immer uns prüfen
lassen müssen ob die Wirkung auch einen
Tritt die wir in der Bildung haben
wollen nämlich die Bildungsgerechtigkeit
das machen wir mit dem Chancen statt
chancenprogramm wir arbeiten mit den
Ländern derzeit am Konzept damit es in
die Umsetzung geht und deswegen wird es
2024 kommen
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin Frau
Ministerin sehr meine Frage nicht
beantwortet wenn das Konzept kommt ich
Frage erneut nach zum zweiten haben sie
von Evaluation gerade gesprochen ich
möchte wissen ob Sie dafür das
Grundgesetz verändern möchten was ja die
Voraussetzung wäre um das zu machen und
dann noch die Frage nach dem Budget sie
haben Balance gesagt ein bis zwei
Milliarden Euro soll das in einem Jahr
stattfinden oder über die 10 Jahre
verteilt und wie wird der Anteil der
Länder sein also das Konzept ist ja
derzeit in der Abstimmung mit den
Ländern es geht auch darum genau um die
Fragen die sie eben angesprochen haben
nach welchem Schlüssel wird das Geld
verteilt da sind die Länder auch
untereinander noch in der Diskussion
geht es um nach Bedürftigkeit oder geht
es nach dem Königsteiner Schlüssel der
ja ein bekanntes Instrument ist das ist
auch etwas was die Länder mit
entscheiden müssen denn die Länder haben
ja bei uns äh in Deutschland eben sind
ja in föderalen Systemen diejenigen die
für Bildung verantwortlich sind und
deswegen dieses Konzept wird natürlich
rechtzeitig kommen dass wir auch für die
Haushaltsberatung 2024 dann auch die
Mittel beantragen können die Höhe ist
natürlich pro Jahr genannt gewesen aber
die genaue Höhe wie es aussieht hängt
von der Ausgestaltung ab auch die Länder
werden ihren Anteil dazu beitragen
müssen und deswegen ist das immer noch
in der Diskussion
gibt es nachfragen zum gleichen Thema
aus der FDP-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Ministerin sie haben
gerade schon zum Thema Stadt
chancenprogramm ausgeführt sie wollen
damit denjenigen helfen die bisher nicht
genug Hilfe bekommen in unserem
Bildungssystem und damit ja auch das
aufstiegsversprechen wieder mit Leben
führen meine Frage ist wir haben den
Königsteiner Schlüssel die Verteilung
der Gelder angesprochen ein Teil der
Gelder soll ja auch für einen
chancenbudget für die Schulen zur
Verfügung stehen die Schulautonomie
Stärken warum es Ihnen das wichtig und
welche Rolle wird das im
stadtschancen-programm am Ende spielen
ja vielen Dank es ist noch mal wichtig
dass wir auch über die Ausgestaltung des
Startchancen Programms sprechen weil es
eben etwas Neues ist es ist auch eine
neue Form der Zusammenarbeit zwischen
den Ländern und dem Bund und es wird
drei Säulen geben einmal das eine
Infrastruktur vorhanden ist die auch
ermöglicht das zusätzliche Förderung
zusätzliche Angebote geschaffen werden
die zweite Säule das chancenbudget damit
die Schulen selbstständig vor Ort
entscheiden können was die Schülerinnen
und Schüler brauchen sei es an
Zusatzangeboten in der Breite oder sei
es eben auch noch mal eine spezielle
Förderung deswegen sind die Schulen auch
selbstständiger das heißt Sie können
Entscheidungen treffen das motiviert
auch die Schulgemeinde zu gestalten und
der die dritte Säule auch ganz wichtig
ist die Schulsozialarbeit nämlich in
diesem Gesamtpaket dass wir auch
wirklich jedes einzelne Kind fördern
können damit jedes einzelne Kind die
Chance hat sich zu entwickeln
sie dürfen müssen aber nicht eine
Nachfrage stellen
gerne eine Nachfrage stellen vielen Dank
Frau Präsidentin meine Frage geht in die
Richtung der also es gibt viele tolle
Konzepte an Schulen auch heute schon
aber leider findet wenig Austausch
bisher statt zwischen den Schulen und
deswegen können gute Ideen häufig nicht
in der Fläche ausgerollt werden wie soll
das sichergestellt werden dass zwischen
den Chancen die am startschancen
Programm teilnehmen aber auch den
Schulen die nicht teilnehmen ein
Wissenstransfer stattfindet so dass alle
Schulen von den guten Erkenntnissen aus
diesem Programm dann auch am Ende
profitieren können ja mit dem Stadt
Chancen Programm das soll ja ein Stück
weit Struktur verändern sein und
Modellcharakter haben wir bauen
natürlich auf das auf was teilweise in
den Ländern auch schon vorhanden ist und
heben es noch mal zusammen auf eine neue
Stufe und deswegen das was der Bund
macht soll ja nicht das Ende der
Förderung sein sondern es soll ja dann
auch sozusagen in die Fläche ausgeweitet
werden deswegen haben wir uns auch für
den Bildungsgipfel im nächsten Jahr der
Stadt findet und der auch ein
Koalitionsvertrag verankert ist auch
dass das Thema Aufstieg versprechen also
dass eben nicht die Größe der Bücher die
Länge der Bücherregale darüber
entscheidet welchen Bildungsweg ein Kind
geht
das haben wir uns zum gemeinsamen Thema
gesetzt und wir werden gleichzeitig eben
auch die Wirksamkeit unserer Maßnahmen
machen denn es langt nicht dass wir Geld
im Haushalt stehen haben sondern es muss
sich wirklich ein Kompetenzen bei den
Schülerinnen und Schülern niederschlagen
vielen Dank ich habe jetzt noch drei
weitere Nachfragen zu diesem Thema und
dann bin ich ab
weil wir dann weiter in die
Fragestellung runtergehen sonst schaffen
wir das wieder nicht in dieser einen
Stunde
jetzt hat aus der CDU CSU-Fraktion die
Kollegin Ludwig eine Nachfrage
frau Präsidentin vielen Dank Frau
Ministerin wir wissen aus dem IQB
Bildungsmonitor das ungefähr 24 Prozent
der Grundschule die Grundfähigkeiten die
Sie brauchen um die Grundschule dann in
Richtung weiterführende Schulen zu
verlassen nicht erreichen
wir wissen auch dass das vermutlich
Zahlen sind die sich noch erhöhen werden
mit ihrem Staat chancenprogramm dass wir
im Grunde auch durchaus nicht verkehrt
finden erreichen sie aber nur zehn
Prozent der Schüler für uns stellt sich
schon die Frage wie schließen Sie diese
Lücke die ja noch größer wird ich will
auch ganz klar sagen nur Probleme
Schulen zu erreichen wird für einen
flächendeckenden gleichen
Bildungsstandard tatsächlich nicht
ausreichend deshalb noch mal ganz klar
wir schließen Sie die Lücke zwischen den
10% der Schulen die sie mit Stadt
Chancen erreichen und den 24% Tendenz
steigen die die Grundfähigkeiten nicht
bekommen
ja der Bund unterstützt ja in vielen
Bereichen nicht nur mit dem
startchancenprogramm wir haben das Gute
Kita-Gesetz jetzt auf den Weg gebracht
und auch das eben angesprochen wurde die
Finanzierung zwischen Auslaufen der
sprachkitas und dem Anlaufen des Guten
kita-gesetzes auch hier hat der Bund die
Finanzierung zur Verfügung gestellt wir
unterstützen beim Ausbau des
ganztagesangebotes auch ein wichtiger
Punkt den Ganztag ist nicht nur das
Familie betreut also betreut wird und
Familie und Beruf vereinbart werden kann
sondern der Ganztag hat auch was mit
Bildungschancen zu tun wir unterstützen
durch die Qualitätsoffensive
Lehrerbildung weil natürlich immer noch
der Mensch im Klassenraum ein
entscheidenden Unterschied macht wir
haben jetzt digitale Kompetenzzentren
auf den Weg gebracht weil nicht nur die
Infrastruktur da stehen muss sondern es
muss auch eingesetzt werden damit
differenzierter Unterricht stattfinden
kann also der Bund unterstützt ja in
einer ganzen Bandbreite aber es ist klar
wenn die Länder in föderalen Systemen
die Verantwortung haben dann wollen wir
einen Mehrwert bieten wir wollen nicht
ersetzen sondern der Bund bietet einen
Mehrwert um diese Ziele zu erreichen die
wir uns setzen das aufstiegsversprechen
zu erneuern
keine Nachfrage mehr dann habe ich als
Frage von Daniela Ludwig und da kann ich
Ihnen schnell sagen was IQB eigentlich
bedeutet das ist das Institut zur
Qualitätsentwicklung im Bildungswesen
und dieses Institut hat vor geraumer
Zeit schon ermittelt wie stark die
Leistung von Schülerinnen und Schülern
in der Grundschule zurückgegangen sind
teilweise werde nicht mal der
Mindeststandard erreicht so hieß es in
diesem iqb-bericht hier ist jetzt an der
Frage Runde beteiligt Nicole höchst aus
der afd-fraktion wirkliche Chancen zu
eröffnen lassen sie auslaufen dabei ist
doch ganz klar dass ohne Deutsch an
Schulen keine Bildungschancen bestehen
meine Frage ist bekennt sich die
Bundesregierung zu deutsch als
Bildungssprache in Deutschland und wenn
ja wie möchten Sie das Sicherstellen mit
welchen Fachpersonal wo wir doch ohnehin
schon Mangel an gut ausgebildeten
pädagogischen Fachkräften im
Kita-Bereich und erst recht an Schulen
haben danke
also sehr geehrte Frau Abgeordnete ich
habe selbst einmal im Ausland gelebt und
ich weiß natürlich selbst dass es auch
für meine Kinder wichtig ist dass Sie
dort die Sprache gelernt haben das ist
ein Teil sich auch in der Lebenswelt zu
Recht zu erfinden und deswegen ist
natürlich auch für die Kinder wichtig
die vielleicht eine andere Muttersprache
haben dass sie eben die Sprache lernen
damit Sie auch in der Schule dann eben
ihren Weg gehen können und insofern ist
es gut dass jetzt mit dem mit den
sprachkitas die Überführung ist gute
Kita-Gesetz stattfindet damit die
Sprachförderung dann auch geschieht ja
es sollte möglichst auch in allen
Bundesländern dann auch die geschaut
werden ob die Sprachkompetenzen da sind
damit man frühzeitig auch noch mal
unterstützen kann wo zusätzlich gelernt
werden muss insofern ist es ein Thema
dass wir als Bundesregierung auch mit
unterstützen weil der
Bildungserfolg für uns etwas Wichtiges
für jeden einzelnen in unserem Land
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen ja ich
würde gerne Nachfassen Frau Ministerin
woher das Fachpersonal kommt dass diese
gut gemeinten
Gesetzesinitiativen unterstützt wir
haben das beim gute Kita-Gesetz schon
gesehen wir hatten in der Fläche in
Rheinland-Pfalz die Leute nicht die zur
Verfügung standen um all diesen Segen an
die Kitas zu bringen und bei einem
Lehrermangel der in den zig tausenden
figuriert würde ich gerne Ausführungen
aus Ihrem Hause von Ihnen hören wie sie
das Stemmen wollen
natürlich nicht sehr gerne Verträge zu
Lasten Dritter weil die Ausbildung von
Lehrern und Erzieherinnen und Erzieher
natürlich nicht auf Bundesebene
angesiedelt ist aber natürlich ist es
eine gemeinsame Aufgabe der wir uns auch
gemeinsam stellen Bund und Land und auch
die Kommunen zusammen und insofern
Fachkräfte fehlen überall da muss man
pragmatisch sein das müssen mehr
Lehrerinnen und Lehrer jetzt in
Ausbildung kommen mehr Ausbildung also
mehr Plätze an den Universitäten
geschaffen werden wir müssen
Quereinsteiger
besser vorbereiten und gut integrieren
damit eben der aktuelle Mangel auch
abgemildert werden kann und muss und
zusätzlich darüber hinaus werden wir ja
auch mit der fachkräftestrategie und
auch mit der fachkräftezuwanderung eben
weitere Maßnahmen schaffen damit der
Fachkräftemangel der uns in der ganzen
Breite in unserem Land sowohl in der
Gesellschaft aber als auch in der
Wirtschaft trifft dass wir ein Stück
weit Abhilfe schaffen können
nächste Nachfrage zum Thema stellt die
Kollegin Staffler aus der
cdu/csu-fraktion Herr besten Dank
das Aufholen nach Corona für unsere
Kinder und Jugendlichen ist ein
dringliches Thema ein dringend nötiges
Thema und zwar nicht erst in einem
halben Jahr nicht erst in einem Jahr die
Kollegen haben darauf hingewiesen und
auch nicht nur für zehn Prozent der
Kinder sondern für alle Kinder deswegen
nochmals die Nachfrage weil wir dazu
bislang noch keine klare Antwort gehört
haben wann kommt das Konzept zu auf zum
Start thorstenprogramm
wie wollen sie die Lücke zwischen den
zehn Prozent die darin vorgesehen sind
der Kinder auf alle Kinder schließen und
die dritte Nachfrage auch die ist nicht
beantwortet planen Sie zum Thema
Evaluation eine Grundgesetzänderung
die das Programm aufholen nach Corona
ist in einer Zeit ins Leben gerufen
worden und auf den Weg gebracht worden
in dem es eine Ausnahmesituation in
unserem Land gab wenn wir uns aber jetzt
anschauen das hat auch die ständige
wissenschaftliche Kommission der KMK
gesagt muss man sich anschauen ob das
Programm in der ganzen Breite effizient
war warum
weil teilweise waren Sommerkurse
teilweise war es freiwilliges Angebot
wir wissen gar nicht ob wir die
Schülerinnen oder Schüler erreicht haben
die wirklich die Unterstützung brauchen
ich möchte aber auch sagen ich habe
tolle Sachen gesehen die mit dem
aufholprogramm passiert ist also
insofern möchte ich das nicht schwarz
zeichnen sondern ich möchte da ein
gemischtes Bild zeigen und deswegen
nehmen wir das ernst was die
Wissenschaftler sagen ah die Förderung
müssen nachhaltig sein ein Sommerkurs
ist nicht ausreichend und deswegen kommt
mitten wir uns auch deswegen geben wir
den Weg zehn Jahre dass der Bund diese
Stadt Chancen Programm im ersten
Durchlauf finanziert das heißt das
Konzept kommt
gleichzeitig zu den Haushaltsberatungen
2024 denn man braucht ein Konzept um es
in die Haushaltsberatungen einbringen zu
können und die Ausgestaltung in welcher
Form wir zusammenarbeiten auf welcher
Basis wir zusammenarbeiten das wird sich
dann auch je nachdem wie das
chancenbudget und andere Maßnahmen auch
ausgestaltet werden wird sich das dann
abzeichnen aber dass man sich
wissenschaftlich begleiten lässt das ist
möglich und das müssen wir auch tun
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen
Dankeschön dabei möchte ich noch mal
zurückkommen auf die Frage nach der
Evaluation planen Sie eine
Grundgesetzänderung
das Angebot steht dass wir eine neue
Form der Zusammenarbeit wählen das tun
wir auch schon indem wir eben dieses
Programm auf den Weg bringen das tun wir
indem ich in die KMK viel öfter geht
gehe und wir einen viel engeren
Austausch jetzt auch haben zusammen und
das Angebot steht aber es muss eben
zielführend sein und vor allen Dingen
muss es so sein dass alle das auch
wollen weil wir können uns natürlich in
Debatten verstricken aber wir müssen ja
jetzt schon anfangen auch wirklich
Programme auf den Weg zu bringen
ich fahre fort in der Liste der
angemeldeten Fragestellerin und als
nächstes hat das Wort Yvonne re aus der
SPD-Fraktion
in dank frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte
Frau Ministerin im Haushaltsverfahren
hat der Deutsche Bundestag erste Mittel
für die Pilotphase der dativi belegt und
da wäre meine Frage in welcher Form ist
mit dem Beginn der Pilotphase im Jahr
2023 zu rechnen und welche Ziele sollen
verfolgt werden für den weiteren
Gründungsprozess der Dativ auf den ja
sehr viele Menschen und auch Akteure
bereits warten und vielleicht können Sie
da auch noch mal darauf eingehen was die
Datei aus ihrer Sicht und aus der Sicht
des Hauses für eine Rolle im Rahmen des
der Transfer und Innovationsförderung
spielen sollen vielen Dank ja ganz
herzlichen Dank liebe Kollegin für die
Frage denn die Dativ ist ja auch eine
Neuerung im innovations- und in
Transferbereich es ist ja eine
innovations- und transferbegriff ist ja
sehr weit aber mit der da die
adressieren wir eben gerade die
Hochschulen für angewandte
Wissenschaften weil dort sehr sehr viel
wirklich angewandte Forschung
stattfindet wir wollen die Ökosysteme
aufbauen vor Ort wo schon Kompetenzen
dar wenn du schon wo schon eine
Grundlage ist aber auch neue Ideen aber
es soll eben aus dem System heraus
geschehen und wir beschränken das nicht
nur auf technologische Innovation
sondern auch die soziale Innovation das
ist uns ganz wichtig der Buchdruck war
ja auch eine soziale Innovation also in
da insofern diese breite wir haben ganz
früh eine stakeholder-prozess ins Leben
gerufen weil es uns auch wichtig ist mit
den Beteiligten und mit in der
Zusammenarbeit und dem Feedback und die
Rückmeldung die wir bekommen dann das
Konzept auch so aufzusetzen dass es
richtig ist es gibt auch eine Online
Beteiligung wir wollen wirklich in der
Breite auch hier im Bereich Transfer
etwas bewegen ich bin sehr froh dass der
Haushaltsausschuss jetzt die ersten
Mittel auch freigegeben hat damit wir
starten können es werden jetzt die
rechtlichen Grundlagen geschaffen damit
wir Anfang nächsten Jahres die Gründung
vollziehen können und die ersten
Projekte dann auch durchführen können
Bettina stark Watzinger mit ihrer
Antwort auf die Frage von je one re aus
der SPD-Fraktion ganz schnell die
Abkürzung Dativ steht für deutsche
Agentur für Transfer und Innovation ja
besonderen Beteiligung der HAW werden ja
noch mal etwas was auch die dative
berücksichtigen soll nämlich das
möglichst viele Akteure zusammenarbeiten
sollen an den Innovationen und da wurde
auch ganz häufig auch der Begriff der
Region anfangs verwendet vielleicht
können Sie dann noch mal darauf eingehen
wie sich dieser regierungsbegriff im
Konzept oder bzw den Planung des BMW F
niederschlagen und warum ist gerade so
wichtig ist die Regionen mitzunehmen ja
der regionsbegriff darf natürlich nicht
so verstanden werden als das mit einem
Zirkel einen Kreis ziehen und das ist
dann was geschehen darf sondern es geht
um die Vernetzung der Akteure und es
geht darum dass eben diese Hochschulen
für angewandte Wissenschaften die ja
Nukleus sein sollen es kann aber auch
die Zusammenarbeit mit Universitäten es
kann die Zusammenarbeit mit
außeruniversitären Forschungsinstituten
sein aber ganz ganz wichtig auch mit der
Zivilgesellschaft mit der Wirtschaft vor
Ort warum ist uns das so wichtig weil
natürlich sprechen wir in diesen Tagen
sehr viel über technologische
Notwendigkeiten durch die Krisen zu
kommen aber wir brauchen gleichzeitig
natürlich auch immer die
gesellschaftlichen Aspekte die
mitberücksichtigt werden und deswegen
diese breite dieses Ökosystem
mitzunehmen das sehen wir in realer
Boden das ist immens wichtig weil nur so
die Umsetzung von neuen Ideen auch
wirklich funktionieren kann
ich habe jetzt zu diesem spannenden
Thema sechs nachfragen die lasse ich zu
und dann gehe ich weiter in der Liste
nur schon mal als kurze vor Ankündigung
wir beginnen mit dem Kollegen Seite aus
der FDP-Fraktion
ja sehr geehrte Frau Ministerin ich habe
eine Nachfrage zum Thema dati dati soll
ja den Transfer in die Wirtschaft in die
Gesellschaft letztendlich voranbringen
das berühmte Tal des Todes überwinden
sie haben das Thema soziale Innovationen
angeführt soziale Innovationen bedeutet
es geht um die Verbesserung von sozialen
Prozessen könnten sie uns da an der
Stelle noch etwas mehr Einblick in
potenzielle Ziele geben und vor allem in
die Frage wie sie die Community spricht
zum Beispiel Kommunen etc in dieses
Thema einbinden weil die sind bisher
eigentlich ja nicht so gewohnt im
Innovationsprozess wenn er sich ja
häufig auf technologische Dinge bezieht
involviert zu werden vielen Dank ja ganz
herzlichen Dank auch noch mal für die
Chance ein Stück weit mehr zu
konkretisieren was mit der Dativ auf den
Weg gebracht werden soll und ich fange
vielleicht noch mal mit einem Satz an
die Date ist nicht ein riesiges Gebäude
aus Stein und Mörtel in dem Hunderte von
Bürokraten sitzen sondern die Daten soll
etwas genau sein was ja in den Kommunen
in den mit den hawws mit den
wissenschaftlichen Einrichtungen
Zivilgesellschaft und Wirtschaft
entwickelt wird und insofern findet von
Anfang an dieser transferstadt und
deswegen ja auch der Fokus auf die
Hochschulen für angewandte
Wissenschaften sie sind übrigens vor Ort
oft auch ein Faktor das Fachkräfte dort
bleiben weil dort schon eine enge
Zusammenarbeit mit der Wirtschaft vor
Ort aber auch mit der Verwaltung vor Ort
stattfindet damit die Fachkräfte vor Ort
ausgebildet werden können und deswegen
also diese diese Entwicklung vor Ort
diese Fokus auf die auf den angewandten
Bereich als Teilbereich des
Innovationsprozesses und des
transferprozesses den wir gestalten
müssen
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen ja
vielen Dank eine Nachfrage jetzt haben
sie gesagt das ist der zweite Teil des
transferprozesses davor liegt aber die
Grundlagenforschung könnten sie uns da
über die wie sich die Regierung des
vorstellt von Grundlagenforschung in die
Tati zu kommen vielen Dank ja die
Grundlagenforschung die Neugier
getriebene Forschung die hat uns sehr
sehr stark gemacht und auch hier fördern
wir als Bund zusätzlich zu den Ländern
natürlich die Grundlagenforschung in
ihrer ganzen Breite mit um die 10
Milliarden Euro im Jahr damit diese
Neugier getriebene Forschung auch
stattfindet weil wir ja die neuen
Herausforderungen nicht mit alten mit
den Wegen mit denen wir schon gegangen
sind bewältigen können und deswegen ist
es wichtig dass eben auch die ähm die
Hochschulen für angewandte
Wissenschaften dann im Zusammenarbeit
mit den außeruniversitären
Forschungsinstituten wo eben auch
Grundlagenforschung stattfindet da auch
die Brücken gebaut werden aber ich
möchte auch noch mal sagen die Dativ ist
ein Teil des transfersystems wir werden
in der Bundesregierung auch auch die
Transfer Brücken für Ausgründungen aus
der Universität noch mal verstärken das
ist ein Teil auch die Ausgründung ein
Teil der Start-up ist Strategie der
Bundesregierung wir haben mit der Sprint
ja die disruptiven Bereich abgedeckt so
dass also die ganze Bandbreite an
Innovation die wir brauchen und den
Transfer den wir brauchen über
verschiedene Instrumente abgebildet
werden kann
so Lernzeit bei Phoenix also nochmal
Dativ deutsche Agentur für Transfer und
Innovation Haws Hochschulen für
angewandte Wissenschaften und jetzt eine
Frage aus der Unionsfraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Ministerin stark
Watzinger der Grundgedanke der Dativ
wird für den von den Hochschulen für
angewandte Wissenschaften von den hhws
positiv gesehen gleichzeitig gibt es
erhebliche Kritik an der geplanten
Ausgestaltung
insbesondere gibt es die Befürchtung
dass die HWS zu wenig Einfluss auf
eigene Projekte haben inwiefern ist das
BMBF geneigt die Forderungen der Haws
insbesondere im Hinblick auf die
konsozialführerschaft der HWS bei durch
die Date geförderten Projekten zu
berücksichtigen
und das war natürlich Michael Kaufmann
aus der afd-fraktion
eine tolle Forschungslandschaft durch
die verschiedenen durch die
verschiedenen Akteure durch die
Universitäten durch die Hochschulen für
angewandte Wissenschaften durch die
außeruniversitären Forschungsinstitute
und die HAW ist also die Hochschulen für
angewandte Wissenschaft sie sind bisher
in den Bereich Transfer und auch in der
Förderung ein Stück weit weniger
berücksichtigen deswegen jetzt der Fokus
auf die Hochschulen für angewandte
Wissenschaft sie sollen eben dort
diejenigen sein die diese Ökosysteme als
die dafür führen wenn man es mal so
bezeichnen möchte Verantwortung insofern
ist es auch etwas wo wir eng Austausch
sind mit den Hochschulen für angewandte
Wissenschaften und auch das was an
Anregungen kam damit es umsetzbar ist
dort auch mit einbeziehen deswegen ja
dieser Breite Stakeholder Prozent und
deswegen erst mit den Leuten sprechen
bevor wir gründen deswegen die runden
die Workshops und jetzt der online
Prozess ich glaube so viel Partizipation
gab es vorher noch nicht und das ist
aber auch richtig so in einer komplexen
Welt brauchen wir die Meinung und die
Anregung von allen die sich dort
beteiligen sie dürfen eine Nachfrage
stellen ja dass die Botschaft höre ich
aber wann werden denn dazu konkrete
Pläne vorgelegt wann erfahren wir denn
wie die konkrete Ausgestaltung aussehen
wird wir haben im Rahmen der Anregungen
die wir bekommen haben wird jetzt das
Finale Konzept erarbeitet wir haben
durch die Entsperrung der Mittel im
Haushalt 2022 jetzt die Möglichkeit auch
die juristischen des juristische wissen
uns noch mal dazu zu nehmen damit wir zu
Beginn nächsten Jahres Gründen können
dann liegt natürlich auch das Konzept
vor und dann werden mit dem Konzept auch
die Mittel für die ersten Ökosysteme
freigesetzt werden und dann wird es
starten und ich freue mich darauf
nächste Frage zum Thema stellt aus der
Fraktion DIE LINKE Frau Sitte
ja besten Dank Frau
Ministerin und wir wahrscheinlich also
ein Kollege von mir hat mal gesagt
Agentur für sprunginnovationen und
Agentur für Innovationen bei der Sprung
Innovation müssen sie Nacharbeiten bei
der Agentur für Forschung und Innovation
hakt es und es soll also erst im Sommer
alles rauskommen nennen sie passen sie
es doch zusammen und nennen Sie es
einfach Späti
nichtsdestotrotz hat der
Haushaltsausschuss jetzt die Mittel
gesperrt sie haben also nur mittelfrei
gegeben bekommen um die da die
aufzustellen konzeptionell bis zum
letzten Jahr hat es aber im Haushalt
eine Summe gegeben von 75 Millionen für
Forschungsprojekte der Fachhochschulen
diese 75 Millionen sind in den Titel
gegangen dem sich jetzt die Dativ
befindet aber natürlich nicht
vollständig es sind nur 65 Millionen die
da reingegangen sind jetzt frage ich sie
jetzt haben wir das Jahr 22 das heißt
sofern die Mittel gesperrt bleiben wie
kommen denn dann hoch wollen an das Geld
dieses alten Titels aus einem
Haushaltstitel der insgesamt aber für
diese dattemittel gesperrt ist wie
überbrücken sie das wie kommen die
Hochschulen an dieses ihnen ja
eigentlich versprochene Geld
ja liebe Kolleginnen Sitte wir begehen
ja mit beiden Agenturen
neue Wege Novum ja warum weil auch eine
Agentur für sprunginnovation die ja
schon in den letzten Legislatur ins
Leben gerufen wurde sie entspricht
natürlich nicht dem was eine
bundeshaushaltsordnung vielleicht so als
Logik hat aber das ist ja gerade das
Ziel dass beide Agenturen eben möglichst
Politik werden sie sollen ja
wissenschaftsgetrieben beziehungsweise
von den Akteuren aus der
Zivilgesellschaft der Verwaltung der
Wirtschaft also in diesem Ökosystem
getrieben sein und das müssen wir
natürlich mit dem was wir als
Haushaltsrecht haben und was ich auch
für sinnvolle achte ich war mal im
haushaltsausschluss ich weiß wir geben
Steuergelder aus muss das über
eingebracht werden und deswegen ist das
natürlich ein komplizierterer Prozess
und die Sperre die wir haben die Titel
zusammengeführt damit man auch insgesamt
mal sieht was passiert in dem Bereich
damit es eine Klarheit auch im Haushalt
gibt aber die Sperre wird natürlich sich
also das müssen die Haushälter dann
entscheiden aber die bezieht sich
natürlich speziell auf die Dativ
die dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen ja
Dankeschön also das heißt Fachhochschule
XY oder Hochschule für angewandte
Wissenschaften kann bezogen auf dieses
alte Programm jetzt nicht in dieser
Titelgruppe bei Ihnen also Themen offen
einen Antrag stellen auf Zugang zu
Mitteln und die zweite der zweite Teil
dieser Nachfrage wann kommt denn jetzt
mal die Kohle an wann wollen Sie denn
oder was ist ihre Zielstellung dass die
Fachhochschulen tatsächlich vor Ort mit
gemeinsam mit anderen Akteuren
tatsächlich an das Geld kommen also
dadurch dass die einzelnen Titel in
dieser Titelgruppe die ist so schön
heißt zusammengefasst werden heißt das
ja wenn sie trotzdem weitergeführt die
Programme ja also wir haben ja jetzt
nicht Programme eingestellt deswegen und
insofern ist natürlich ein
Antragsverfahren in den bestehenden
Programmen so wie es vorgesehen ist
möglich so und jetzt wenn ich mich
speziell auf die Dativ beziehe da haben
wir ja gesagt Gründung Anfang nächsten
Jahres und dann natürlich auch zügig die
die das bewerben um die ersten
projektprojekte
nur zu Erklärung an die beiden
Kolleginnen aus der cdu/csu-fraktion sie
sind etwas später reingekommen ich habe
gesagt ich lasse sechs Nachfragen zu
deswegen habe ich gerade den Kopf
geschüttelt also aber jetzt kommt aus
der cdu/csu-fraktion die nächste Frage
zum Thema von Herrn Albani
ja herzlichen Dank sie sehen mich ganz
ruhig was das dran kommen anbelangt aber
in keiner Weise ruhig was die Datei
anbelangt
das erste Papier war für März diesen
Jahres angekündigt und das war schon die
konkreteste Datum was wir je bekommen
haben heute ist es noch etwas wieder
debolöser geworden und wenn man sich die
Zeitraum anguckt indem wir jetzt schon
über die dati diskutieren mag man
durchaus die Sorgen die hier aus den
Stimmen kommen was mit dem Geldern
passiert und was mit der Struktur
passiert teilen und damit ich hier jetzt
gar nicht auf mich selber und meine
Sorgen eingebe möchte ich ihren
ehemaligen Staatssekretär kritisieren
der an dieser Stelle vor kurzem per
Twitter schreibt weil da die gibt es
nichts gesund zu beten 70% gesperrt BMWF
an der Kandare
die Wahrscheinlichkeit dass aus dati
eine miniaturfigur wird und die hawws
bei anwendungsorientierter Forschung in
die Röhre gucken ist extrem hoch das
sind die Sorgen die mit denen wir Ihnen
sie seit einem halben Jahr konfrontieren
dann jetzt zu sagen wir sind in einem
europäischen Prozess und auch noch zu
sagen die sie ist Teil unserer
Infrastruktur sie könnte es wenn man
diese Probleme lösen können warum lösen
Sie sie nicht ja sehr geehrter Herr
Kollege Albani ich hätte mir ja
gewünscht dass in den letzten 16 Jahren
dann ins Transfersystem in seiner ganzen
Breite schon mal so aufgestellt worden
wäre und wenn ich mir den wenn ich mir
den Prozess zur ins Leben rufen der
Agentur für sprunginnovationen anschauen
wenn ich sehe wie der Leiter der Agentur
für sprunginnovation erstmal um
E-Mail-Adressen kämpfen musste dann
würde ich sagen sind wir doch gut
unterwegs aber ich will nehmen das Thema
natürlich ernst weil es geht ja wirklich
darum Innovation und Transfer in unserem
Land voranzubringen und deswegen haben
wir alle mit Hochdruck dran gearbeitet
und sind auch noch mit Hochdruck dran
aber ich wiederholst noch mal es geht
darum dass wir den Gründungsprozess so
schaffen dass wir nicht nachsteuern
müssen wie bei der Agentur für Sprung
Innovation wo wir jetzt ein
freiheitsgesetz auf den Weg bringen
müssen sondern dass wir von Anfang an
die Agentur für Transfer und Innovation
so aufstellen dass Sie Ihren Auftrag
gerecht wird und das auch möglichst
viele sich dort bewerben und möglichst
viele Ökosysteme dann ins Leben gerufen
werden und nächstes Anfang nächsten
Jahres ist unsere Ziel ist unser Ziel
und da sind alle in der Koalition dran
daran zu arbeiten und deswegen freue ich
mich wenn das nächste Jahr startet sie
dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen herzlichen
Dank
der Hinweis auf die letzten 16 Jahre ist
so einfallslos wie unkorrekt an dieser
Tatsache was das kann ich Ihnen als
Wissenschaftler der in die Politik
gegangen ist sagen in den letzten 16
Jahren ist die Wissenschaft eine Menge
Geschehen eine Menge geschehen und
insofern ist es jetzt auch wichtig die
Dinge zu kritisieren die jetzt geschehen
müssen und das sind die Dinge die Sie
jetzt hier an dieser Stelle verantworten
und deswegen noch einmal die Dativ ist
der als eine Institution insbesondere
für die hawws auf den Weg gebracht
worden als solches wird sie auch von der
Community erwartet es wurde dann im
Laufe der Zeit der Kreis derer die sich
daran beteiligen erweitert das Geld was
aber da reingeflossen ist es bisher aus
den originären Titeln der Haws forschen
an Fachhochschulen heißt dieser eine
Titel wie können sie verantworten an
dieser Stelle Gelder dort
hineinzubringen und an anderer Stelle
den Hochschulen hier nicht klar zu sagen
wer am Ende hier bei partizipieren wird
also sehr Gelehrter
gelehrt sind sie auch als
Wissenschaftler geehrter Herr Kollege
Albani
ich nehme Kritik immer ernst aber
vielleicht nehmen sie Kritik auch ernst
weil im Bereich Innovation und Transfer
wie gesagt Agentur für Sprung Innovation
und eine Dativ habe ich bisher noch
nicht gesehen so es ist so dass auch
zusätzliche Mittel dafür zur Verfügung
gestellt werden das was Sie gesagt haben
den wieder spreche ich also und es ist
natürlich eine Aufbauphase von einer
Agentur was nützt ist mir jetzt viele
Gelder ich hätte natürlich wächst ja auf
der dati Haushalt was nützt es uns zu
Beginn des Haushaltsjahres Mittel drins
stehen zu haben wir müssen jetzt in die
Umsetzung kommen das ist unser Ziel und
da sind wir im engen Austausch mit den
HWS und haben auch das Gefühl dass wir
da die Kommunikation gut auf Augenhöhe
haben und auch die Haws immer im Bild
sind wo der Stand bei uns der Prozess
ist
nächste Frage zu diesem Thema stellt aus
der FDP-Fraktion Frau Schröder
danke Frau Präsidentin liebe Frau
Ministerin sie haben eben neben dem
Thema technologische Innovation auch das
Thema soziale Innovationen angesprochen
jetzt haben sie in diesem Jahr sogar
extra eine Beauftragte für das Thema ins
Ministerium geholt die erfahrene
sozialunternehmerin Sarah Bruhn ich
glaube viele Menschen haben vielleicht
noch gar keine richtige Vorstellung
davon was heißt das eigentlich soziale
Innovation wie verhält sich das zu
technologischen Innovationen und warum
ist es überhaupt etwas was man fördern
sollte deswegen meine Frage an Sie wie
werden soziale Innovationen aus dem BMWF
herausgefordert und warum tun sie das
überhaupt ja ganz herzlichen Dank Frau
Kollegin Schröder das ist ein
Herzensanliegen gewesen auch von dieser
Koalition dass wir dem Thema soziale
Innovationen auch noch mal einen
zusätzlichen Raum geben soziale
Innovationen das ist nicht etwas sehr
abstraktes wer in den letzten Wochen und
Monaten gesehen hat die Flüchtlinge die
aus der Ukraine zu uns gekommen sind wie
auch junge Unternehmen die in dem
Bereich soziale Innovationen tätig sind
mit unterstützt haben zum Beispiel bei
der Wohnungsvermittlung aber auch bei
der Vermittlung in den Arbeitsmarkt hat
gesehen dass natürlich dort durch diese
guten Ideen unkompliziert auch Lösungen
für soziale Herausforderungen und
gesellschaftliche Herausforderungen zu
finden eben immens wichtig sind und
deswegen haben wir diesem Thema auch ein
Gesicht gegeben und
unsere beauftragte Frau Bruhn ist im
Augenblick hat ihre Strategie auch die
Bausteine die dazugehören auch jetzt
ausgearbeitet und wird sie auch
vorstellen zum Beispiel ein konkretes
Beispiel damit auch nicht im luftleeren
Raum bleibt ist das dann auch
Förderlinien für soziale Innovationen
geöffnet werden weil ich habe schon mal
gesagt Buchdruck oder wenn sie an der
hardenbergischen Reformen die liegen
zwar schon bisschen zurück aber das sind
disruptive Dinge gewesen Veränderung
gewesen die im Bereich soziale
Innovation liegen
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen ja sie
haben eben in dem Zusammenhang auch das
Thema Ausgründung angesprochen ich kenne
aus meinem Wahlkreis von der TU
Hamburg-Harburg das Startup dog wo das
eine ganz große Rolle spielt die können
denn soziale Innovationen im Bereich der
Ausgründung aus Universitäten und auch
in der Stadt ist start-up-strategie der
Bundesregierung wie finden die sich da
wieder und wie greift das auch mit der
Strategie die Sie gerade angesprochen
haben im Bereich soziale Innovation
zusammen ja das Thema Ausgründungen ist
ein wichtiges Thema in verschiedenen
Ministerien der Bundesregierung und
deswegen ist es auch gut wenn wir die
Zukunftsstrategie Forschung und
Innovation dort soll ja auch die Frage
Transfer und Ausgründungen Instrumente
mit ein Teil sein auch hier Ressort
übergreifend denken denn wir brauchen
diese Ausgründungen ihrer ganzen Breite
und ich finde das immer wenn sie mal
unterwegs sind landaufverland ab in den
Hochschulen in den Universitäten was
dort wirklich an Elan ist und auch in
der Gründerszene im Bereich soziale
Innovation ich habe eben schon Beispiele
genannt wie betreut man Flüchtlinge aber
wie löst man auch Probleme in der
corona-pandemie wie kann man älteren
Menschen dann noch eine Versorgung
ermöglichen also diese Ideen aber eben
auch wenn es um den Bekämpfung des
Klimawandels geht sieht man ja dass hier
unheimlich viel auch Motivation ist dass
wir zusammen diese Probleme lösen und
deswegen werden die Ausgründungen in
Teil dieser Innovationsstrategie eine
große Rolle spielen
letzte Fragesteller zu diesem Thema
zumindest
aus der cdu/csu-fraktion hey ja zum weg
frau Präsidentin Frau Ministerin sie
haben sie sind ja angetreten mit dem
Versprechen
forschungstechnologie besser in die
Fabriken und auf die Straße zu bringen
und wenn wir jetzt mal konkret gucken
wir haben aktuell das Thema der
Energiekrise und da hat Fraunhofer
Solarzellen entwickelt die sind dreimal
so effizient wie heute und wenn die
jetzt also tatsächlich vom Labor in die
Fabrik auf die Dächer kommen dann würde
ab morgen auf jedem neuen Haus dreimal
so viel Solarstrom erzeugt immer noch
werden aber veraltete Solarzellen auf
Häuserdächer gebaut weil das irgendwie
aus Hannover nicht rauskommt jetzt
machen sie diese transfer-agentur und
erklären Sie uns doch mal warum diese
Datei oder Späti oder wie auch immer das
Ding heizen soll erklären Sie uns doch
mal warum diese Agentur genauso Vorhaben
nicht fördert warum Fraunhofer
ausgeschlossen ist Helmholz
ausgeschlossen ist die exzellenten
Technischen Universitäten ausgeschlossen
sind wie soll denn Hightech Transfer
stattfinden wenn Sie die besten Akteure
ausgeschlossen haben
ja sehr geehrter Herr zombeck sie
müssten es eigentlich besser wissen und
ich habe es eben auch schon mal gesagt
die dati ist nicht alles was passiert im
Bereich Transfer sie ist ein ganz
spezielles Instrument das noch mal einen
Potenzial gibt dass wir bisher nicht
gehoben haben in unserem Land und es
geht ja nicht darum ein einzelnes
Produkt auf den Markt zu bringen das ist
immens wichtig aber das ist nicht Sinn
der Dativ sondern dafür gibt es andere
Förderlinien ja sondern die da die soll
ja auch diesen Innovationsprozess
erstmal befördern und insofern ist Ihre
Frage viel zu kurz gegriffen wenn es mit
Blick auf die wenn es um die Date geht
dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen vielen
Dank ja Frau Ministerin dann erklären
Sie uns das doch mal wie sie das jetzt
machen also die drei Mal so effizienten
Solarzellen sind dabei Fraunhofer die
sind fast fertig es gibt auch viermal so
effiziente energieräder was tun Sie
jetzt und das ins Labor in die Fabrik zu
bringen also
ja zumbeck auch das wissen sie aus der
Zeit in der sie in der Bundesregierung
waren aber ich erkläre ihnen das noch
mal gerne sie wissen natürlich auch dass
die außeruniversitären
Forschungsinstitute eine selbst schon
Transfer Innovation
transferprogramme haben es gibt zum
Beispiel auch bei außeruniversitären
Forschungsinstituten dann Fonds die
genau das finanzieren dass eben die
Innovation auch den Markt Hochlauf
schaffen kann es gibt in Zusammenarbeit
mit dem bmwk auch Förderprogramme die
eben neue innovative
Technologien in die Breite bringen
können es gibt auch im BMWs gibt es auch
KMU innovativ es gibt also zusätzlich
Förderprogramme die Möglichkeit
Möglichkeiten schaffen auch Innovationen
zu finanzieren
ich gehe weiter in die angemeldeten
Fragen und als nächstes stellt die Frage
aus der afd-fraktion Frau höchst
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin Frau
Ministerin der Fachkräftemangel ist in
so vielerlei Hinsicht über die letzten
Jahrzehnte selbstgemacht dass mir jetzt
die Zeit fehlt das alles darzustellen
deswegen mein Fokus auf zwei Probleme
mit denen unser duales Ausbildungssystem
kämpft erstens ein Studium ist immer
noch gesellschaftlich attraktiver gerade
bei Schulabsolventen als eine duale
Ausbildung zweitens stark mit
öffentlicher Wertschätzung aufgeladene
Berufe wie zum Beispiel klimamanager
oder
Gleichstellungsbeauftragte werden sehr
viel häufiger angestrebt als Berufe bei
denen man sich körperlich sehr
anstrengen muss oder sich womöglich
sogar die Hände schmutzig macht gibt es
irgendeine eine Idee oder eine ein
Maßnahmenkatalog wie sie diesen
Problemen zu Leibe rücken wollen oder
ist das für sie gar kein Problem
der Fachkräftemangel ist etwas was
unsere Wirtschaft und unseren Wohlstand
stark belastet wir haben heute schon
zwei Millionen offene Stellen
unbesetzte Stellen das nimmt Zukunft und
wir brauchen kluge Köpfe und die
fleißigen Hände auch aus der beruflichen
Bildung und deswegen haben wir uns auch
auf den Weg gemacht und von Anfang an
gesagt der Weg in einer akademischen
Ausbildung und der Weg in eine
beruflichen Ausbildung sie sind
unterschiedlich aber sie sind
gleichwertig wir brauchen ein Umdenken
in den Köpfen denn bei uns ist eine
berufliche Ausbildung der Ausgangspunkt
für eine wunderbare berufliche Karriere
was man bei uns in der beruflichen
Ausbildung lernt das muss man den
anderen Ländern studieren und es kommt
bei uns noch der Praxis in Bezug dazu
die jungen Menschen
wollen ja auch etwas verändern was
machen wir jetzt als Bundesregierung wir
haben die fachkräftestrategie auf den
Weg gebracht das ist ein Bündel von
verschiedenen Maßnahmen ich will mal
zwei exemplarisch draußen nehmen das
eine ist natürlich die berufsorien
Regierung das überhaupt die Schülerinnen
und Schüler in allen Schulformen wissen
was ist eigentlich für
Berufsmöglichkeiten und was kann ich
damit bewirken zum Beispiel indem ich
die Technologien verbaue die den
Klimawandel bekämpfen die
Berufsorientierung werden wir noch mal
stärken und die Exzellenzinitiative
berufliche Bildung um den Stellenwert zu
unterstreichen den diese wichtige
berufliche Bildung bei uns hat denn das
sind die Macher von morgen und das ist
unsere Wirtschaft von morgen
[Applaus]
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen
vielen Dank das möchte ich auch gerne
Frau Ministerin sie sind mir noch eine
Antwort schuldig auf meine Frage vorhin
ob sich die Bundesregierung zu deutsch
als Bildungssprache in Deutschland
bekennt in den Klassenzimmern herrscht
immer häufiger Englisch vor als Lingua
franca weil so viele Kinder mit nicht
deutscher muttersprachlichen Hintergrund
in diesen Klassen sind dass ein
Unterricht in deutscher Sprache vielfach
nicht mehr möglich ist also holen Sie
das bitte nach wie Sie das sehen und
wenn Sie das so sehen dass Deutsch die
Unterrichtssprache in Deutschland sein
sollen dann möchte ich Sie bitten
darzustellen wie dieses Bekenntnis auch
mit Leben gefüllt werden kann denn
wieder Lehrer Präsident Meininger schon
sagte viele Migranten in den Klassen
sind ursächlich für schlechtere
Schulleistungen also frei zitiert und
das liegt nicht in den Migranten sondern
in der Sprachkompetenz begründet die
wollen Sie begegnen vielen Dank also
Frau Abgeordnete höchst ich habe es eben
schon gesagt ich habe auch mal im
Ausland gelernt weil dieses betonen von
Deutsch es geht nicht um Deutsch als
Deutsch sondern es geht darum dass man
die Sprache die in einem Land ist auch
versucht zu erwerben damit man sich
zurechtfinden kann und das ist die
Grundlage von allem und natürlich ist es
so dass das in den Schulen auch schon in
den Kitas deswegen ja auch gute
Kita-Gesetz die Grundlage sein soll aber
ich möchte eines zurückweisen was sie
eben gesagt haben dass das der Grund
dafür ist dass Schulen heute diese
Herausforderung haben die Zuwanderung
das Problem ist dass wir nicht genug
klären und Lehrer haben die die jungen
Menschen die zu uns kommen auch
unterstützen auf dem Weg hier die
Sprache zu lernen deswegen möchte ich
das von dem Konnotation her wirklich
noch mal anders darstellen und jetzt
möchte ich noch ein letztes sagen ich
halte es für immens wichtig dass wir zum
Beispiel in den Universitäten auch
frisch als sprach haben denn wir wollen
international sein als Land wir wollen
auch international das kluge Köpfe zu
uns kommen und deswegen müssen wir auch
hier die Offenheit haben und deswegen
kann man nicht eins gegen das andere
ausspielen und deswegen muss man auch
immer Ursache und Wirkung darf man nicht
verwechseln in dieser Diskussion sonst
führt man das auf eine schiefe Ebene die
niemanden hilft
so ich bitte erstens alle Beteiligten
nochmal auf diesen roten Balken zu
achten das heißt dann ist die Zeit
abgelaufen sowohl für die die Fragen
stellen aber auch die die Antworten von
Ministerin jetzt habe ich eine ganz
andere große Herausforderung die ich zu
lösen habe ich habe nämlich jetzt
mindestens schon zu diesem Thema die die
ich gesehen habe 9
Rückfragen nachfragen
nein auch die Union hat sich so ich ja
ich habe aber auch noch drei Fraktionen
die offiziell Fragestellungen angemeldet
haben auch das muss ich in dieser Zeit
die wir noch die uns noch bleibt nämlich
eigentlich 15 Minuten berücksichtigen
möglicherweise werde ich jetzt wieder
verlängern müssen das werde ich dann
gleich dem meiner Ablösung mitteilen
aber ich will eins sagen ich habe drei
Meldungen aus der FDP-Fraktion ich würde
darum bitten dass man sich vielleicht
auf ein Kollegen konzentriert aus der
SPD-Fraktion habe ich auch mehrere
gesehen auch da würde ich darum bitten
vielleicht sich auf einen eine Kollegin
zu konzentrieren wenn das geht
bei den Kollegen Kolleginnen der Grünen
haben wir zwei Meldungen auch das wäre
nett wenn man sich auf eine
konzentrieren könnte dann hätten wir
nämlich bei den nachfragen die ich jetzt
hier aufgeschrieben habe aus jeder
Fraktion jeweils eine Kollegin einen
Kollegen die Nachfragen ich sehe
allgemeines nicken es wäre ich wäre
wirklich sehr dankbar wenn man das so
kollegial lösen könnten und dann würde
ich beginnen mit der FDP-Fraktion mit
dem Kollegen der jetzt die erste
Nachfrage zum Thema stellt ganz
herzlichen Dank Frau Präsidentin Frau
Ministerin wir haben ja das Problem
Fachkräfte Sicherung etwas was sie ja
auch übernommen haben in den letzten
Jahren hat man viel darüber gesprochen
man hat aber nichts getan um wirklich
darauf voranzukommen sie gehen jetzt in
ihren Schritten voran also einmal die
Exzellenzinitiative berufliche Bildung
und dazu gehört ja auch dass wir uns
sehr offen gegenüber der
erwerbsmigration zeigen und da haben sie
ja heute glaube ich ein richtig großen
Schritt getan ich würde mal
interessieren wie weit sie da gekommen
sind und deutsche Erfolge wir da auch
vermählen können dass wir in den
nächsten Jahren machen werden
ja ganz herzlichen Dank für die Frage
weil wir tun natürlich im Rahmen der
fachkräftestrategie und der nationalen
weiterbildungsstrategie alles daran auch
die Menschen im Inland die noch nicht
mehr Erwerbsleben sind entweder zu
motivieren oder auch zu befähigen dass
sie eben einer Arbeit nachgehen können
durch Weiterbildung durch Anerkennung
von Qualifikationen eben auch durch den
Übergang wenn kein Schulabschluss
erworben werden können aber das wird
nicht lange wir brauchen die Zuwanderung
in den in den Arbeitsmarkt deswegen bin
ich froh dass wir heute etwas
beschlossen haben was längst überfällig
war was schon viel früher hätte
passieren müssen nämlich dass wir eine
klare Regelung haben wie in den
Arbeitsmarkt zugewandert wird nicht nur
für Akademiker denn wir sehen das auch
die Gaststätten Probleme haben offen zu
bleiben wir sehen das teilweise kleine
Unternehmen kleine Betriebe schließen
müssen tageweise weil sie eben nicht
mehr die Arbeitskräfte haben und
deswegen drei Säulen wie man in unser
Land einwandern kann in den Arbeitsmarkt
das bleibt natürlich die Fach sanfte
Säule es ist aber auch die
erfahrungssäule wenn jemand schon einen
Ausbildung im Ausland hatte dass er dann
hier einwandern kann und dann also zu
Arbeit finden kann und dann die
Anerkennung erfolgt und eine
potenzialsäure ein ein Punktesystem nach
kanadischen Modell damit wir wirklich in
der ganzen Breite die Hände bekommen die
wir brauchen
eine Nachfrage stellen ganz herzlichen
Dank Frau Ministerin das können sie ja
nicht allein machen sondern das finde
ich auch richtig gut dann müssen wir
mehrere Ministerien zusammenarbeiten wie
es da der Stand der Dinge also wir haben
heute zusammen unter der Federführung
des Bundesministerium für Arbeit und
Soziales die Eckpunkte für ein modernes
Einwanderungsgesetz auf den Weg gebracht
in Zusammenarbeit mit der
bundesinnenministerin mit dem
Bundeswirtschaftsminister und eben auch
dem BMWF und das Auswärtige Amt ist
natürlich auch natürlich durch die
Erteilung der Aufenthaltsgenehmigung
auch mit insofern ist es ein gutes
Beispiel dafür dass eine hervorragende
Zusammenarbeit dann auch schnell
Ergebnisse liefern kann innerhalb ein
Jahres das auf dem Weg gebracht zu haben
ist wichtig denn es ist in der
Vergangenheit schon zu viel Zeit
verloren und wir müssen jetzt dringend
handeln
die nächste Nachfrage zum Thema stellt
aus der Fraktion DIE LINKE Frau Gohlke
frau Präsidentin ja Frau Ministerin ich
will gerne auf den Zustand der
Berufsschulen zu sprechen kommen
mittlerweile sind ja flächendeckend
wirklich in ganz vielen
Bildungseinrichtungen ganz gravierende
Mängel vorhanden in den Schulen in den
Hochschulen Kloß und unbenutzbar Fenster
lassen sich nicht öffnen und so weiter
und in auch in den Berufsschulen beläuft
sich der Sanierungsstau auf mindestens 5
Milliarden Euro und da sind die
Modernisierungskosten noch gar nicht mit
einberechnet dieser war natürlich ganz
ganz dringend bräuchte um die Azubis
auch auf die technologischen
Herausforderungen vorzubereiten die
Ampelkoalition hat sich verpflichtet
gemeinsam mit den Ländern und Kommunen
ja einen Pakt für berufsbildende Schulen
ins Leben zu rufen aber man muss einfach
konzentrieren auch nach einem Jahr liegt
nichts auf dem Tisch auch in dem
Haushalt gibt es findet sich nicht mal
eine Andeutung dazu deswegen jetzt meine
Frage wann geht es los können Sie uns
irgendetwas konkretes zur Ausgestaltung
sagen und sozusagen ja oder machen sie
sich ich sag mal so bei den Schulen und
Hochschulen hat man immer das Gefühl sie
machen sich so ein bisschen schlanken
Fuß also sozusagen dann wird dann gerne
auf die Länder und die Kommunen
verwiesen die doch irgendwie aktiv
werden sollen hier hoffentlich verhält
es sich zumindest anders wann werden Sie
aktiv
ich darf ich nur einmal sagen sie dürfen
das jetzt beantworten aber eigentlich
geht sind wir immer noch im Bereich der
Nachfragen zu Ursprungsfrage
ich will nur noch mal darauf hinweisen
ja sehr geehrte Frau Abgeordnete Gohlke
ich weise zurück dass der Bund sich hier
in schlanken Fuß macht wir haben gerade
vor der Herausforderung dass die
Hochschulen und die Schulen durch die
hohen Energiepreise sehr stark belastet
sind hat der Bund sich sehr stark
eingebracht ca 2 Milliarden Euro werden
aus den ähm aus den Paketen die der Bund
für die Entlastung im Bereich Strom und
Gaspreis auf den Weg gebracht hat
profitieren davon entladen mit entlasten
wir auch die Länder ich möchte also
zurückweisen dass wir uns Schlangen Fuß
machen als Bundesregierung konkret zu
Ihrer Frage man kann natürlich nicht die
die Menschen die unsere Zukunft
gestalten worden in Bildungsorte der
Vergangenheit stecken aber natürlich
werden wir in diesen Pakt für berufliche
Schulen das ist ja ähm sind verschiedene
Maßnahmen die Länder werden ihren Teil
einbringen und wir werden unseren Teil
einbringen und deswegen ist es jetzt auf
den Weg gebracht das wird auch
Zusammenhängen mit allen anderen
Maßnahmen die wir eben im Bereich
berufliche Bildung auf den Weg bringen
deswegen wird jetzt der Dialog mit den
Ländern in Angriff genommen denn sie
haben es gesagt es ist natürlich eine
Arbeitsteilung in unserem Land und wenn
ich auf die Hochschulen schaue dort
haben die Hochschulen wollten ja die die
Verantwortung für den Hochschulbau haben
haben dafür auch in flechtungsmittel
bekommen das heißt also die
Arbeitsaufteilung die muss auch klar
sein weil dann natürlich auch
Finanzströme dahinter hängen aber es ist
klar dass wir alle das gemeinsame Ziel
haben dass die Ausbildungsstätten gerade
in der beruflichen Bildung auch dem
aktuellen Standard entsprechend und
zukunftsweisend sind
sie dürfen eine Nachfrage stellen
also ich habe jetzt gar nichts Konkretes
eigentlich gehört zur Ausgestaltung das
packt das für berufsbildende Schulen
deswegen würde ich jetzt einfach
nachfragen was sie dann konkret
einbringen werden also was sind
sozusagen ihre Stellschrauben ihre
Momente die sie ein als Ministerin
einbringen wollen in diesen
Verhandlungen ich denke mal an solche
Sachen kostenfreies azubi-ticket
Förderung von Wohnheimen für Azubis
verbesserte Lernmittelfreiheit für
Bücher aber auch natürlich für digitale
Endgeräte aber zum Beispiel auch
Verbesserung der Arbeitsbedingungen für
die berufsschullehrerinnen und Lehrer
weil er sozusagen an dem Punkt krank ist
ja auch das wären ja alles
Stellschrauben um die Attraktivität der
beruflichen Bildung wirklich sozusagen
nach vorne zu bringen was sind ihre
Punkte die sie als Ministerin in die
Verhandlungen einbringen werden sehr
geehrte Frau Abgeordnete Gohlke ich
bitte Sie doch auch unser Grundgesetz zu
berücksichtigen in dieser ganzen
Diskussion und der Bund hat zum Beispiel
über den digitalpakt da fallen auch die
beruflichen Schulen darunter ja auch
schon einen Beitrag geleistet um eben
die Schulen zu modernisieren
wir über die über die Qualitätsoffensive
Lehrerbildung über jetzt auch die
Kompetenzzentren für digitale Lehre es
geht ja nicht nur darum Geräte in einen
Raum zu stellen sondern es geht auch
darum dass digitale Möglichkeiten Einzug
halten all das sind Dinge die wir im
Augenblick schon machen wir beginnen
jetzt die Diskussion über den Pakt und
dann wird werden die Länder ihren
Beitrag leisten und der Bund wird seinen
Beitrag leisten aber das diskutieren wir
erst mit den Ländern und dann im
Parlament
die nächste Nachfrage stellt die
Kollegin rosenthal
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin liebe Frau
Ministerin ich bin sehr dankbar dass sie
gerade das Feld der Berufsorientierung
noch mal stark unterstrichen haben auch
noch mal die Qualität von Ausbildung
unterstrichen haben aber was ja auch ein
Teil gerade der Attraktivität von
Ausbildung ist ist dass es auch danach
noch weitergehen kann also die
Verzahnung von Weiterbildung und
Ausbildung auch hier haben wir uns als
Koalition einiges vorgenommen mit Blick
auf das aufstiegs-bafög und mich würde
einmal interessieren wie ihre
Perspektive auf die großen Reformen die
wir uns da vorgestellt haben ist und wie
der Stand auch seitens Ihres Hauses da
ist
ja liebe Frau Kollegin Rosenthal eine
Minute ist immer zu kurz um alles zu
beantworten und in der Tat ist es so
dass das die berufliche Ausbildung
erstmal ein Staat ist es hat ja dann
auch durch den DQR also den
Qualitätsrahmen auch die eben die
Möglichkeit hinterher auch noch andere
Wege einzuschlagen das ist immens
wichtig und das müssen wir jetzt auch
mehr mit Leben füllen mit Blick auf die
Frage wie es danach weitergeht wenn ich
Sie richtig verstanden habe ist es
natürlich so dass dass wir insgesamt das
Berufsbild attraktiver machen wollen
oder die Ausbildung auch attraktiver
machen wollen indem wir internationale
Mobilität ermöglichen indem wir das
Aufstiegs Bafög das war auch eines ihrer
Kernanliegen eben auch reformieren das
ist ja mit den Bafög jetzt auch schon
sind die Rahmenbedingungen verbessert
worden und beim Aufstiegs Bafög ist
heute schon mehr möglich als manchmal in
der öffentlichen Wahrnehmung auch
vorhanden ist also ich rate auch jedem
der sich Video interessiert sich
wirklich mal damit auseinandersetzen und
zu wählen damit man vielleicht auch über
zum Beispiel die Frage
teilzeitausbildungen und ähnliches das
sind Themen den muss man sich nähern
immer in der Abwägung zwischen es soll
natürlich ist eine soziale Unterstützung
die man leistet aber insofern diese
Modernisierung die ist zum Teil jetzt
schon möglich und wir werden die
weiteren Schritte auch mit der weiteren
bafög-reform gehen
die nächsten Nachfrage stellt der
Abgeordnete
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Frau Ministerin ich komme noch
mal auf die Ausgangsfrage zurück sie
haben ja auch in ihrem Eingangsstatement
den nationalen Bildungsbericht erwähnt
ein wichtiger Indikator auch für uns ich
finde dort auf der Seite 80 eine
interessante Angabe da geht es nämlich
um den Zusammenhang zwischen
Migrationshintergrund und Bildungsstand
beziehungsweise Bildungsabschluss und
dort ist zu lesen dass 32 Prozent der
bei uns lebenden jungen Erwachsenen 19
Jahre und
älter über keinerlei Bildungsabschluss
oder beruflichen Abschluss verfügen in
der Gesamtbevölkerung beträgt diese
Anteil nur acht Prozent 32 Prozent das
ist ein Riesenproblem denn wer keinen
Berufsabschluss hat hat natürlich auch
ein Problem ein Beruf zu finden was sind
ihre Ideen was sind die Strategien der
Bundesregierung und von diesen 32
Prozent runterzukommen
jeder junge Mensch der die Schule
verlässt ohne Abschluss das hat
vielfältige Gründe wenn man zum Beispiel
in unser Land zugereist ist kann das
auch der Grund sein dass man relativ
spät in ein Bildungssystem gekommen ist
jeder Mensch muss dann noch die
Möglichkeit haben sich weiter zu
entwickeln deswegen ist es ganz wichtig
dass wir die Übergangsphase gestalten da
sind wir auch in an der Schnittstelle
zusammen mit dem Bundesministerium für
Arbeit und Soziales damit eben der
Übergang in Ausbildung die
Nachqualifikation möglich ist es ist
aber auch immens wichtig dass wir
Kompetenzen die erworben wurden die
vielleicht nicht in der formalen
Ausbildung stattgefunden haben dass wir
die aber feststellen können weil wenn
jemand schon eine Weile arbeitet dann
entwickelte auch erwirbt er auch
Kompetenzen wir haben zum Beispiel das
Programm Walli kommt indem man eben
genau das validieren kann damit man
hinterher auch wenn man auf Arbeitsplatz
Suche ist auch zeigen kann dass man
etwas kann das ist immens wichtig
deswegen das eine ist natürlich dass
auch im Bereich Schule dort
die Zahl derjenigen die die Schule ohne
Abschluss verlässt sinkt und dass wir
aber denjenigen die dann die Schule so
verlassen haben leider die Brücke bauen
in die Arbeitswelt und in den langen
beruflichen Lebensweg
die Kollegin rheinalter stellt die
nächste Nachfrage ach so entschuldigung
ich habe das habe ich jetzt nicht
gesehen wenn sie gestanden hätte ich
noch eine Nachfrage auch dazu werden wir
jetzt den Status quoons angeguckt wir
müssen aber auch in die Zukunft blicken
Deutschland hat ja extrem hohe Steuern
im internationalen Vergleich bis fast 50
Prozent wir haben leider teilweise auch
mal eine marode Infrastruktur marode
Schulen teilweise sind die Innenstädte
nicht mehr sicher was macht sie denn so
sicher dass ausgerechnet jetzt
Erleichterung bei der Zuwanderung und
Erleichterung beim Erwerb der deutschen
Staatsbürgerschaft echte Fachkräfte
diverse wirklich brauchen motivieren
könnte nun ausgerechnet nach Deutschland
zu kommen ist das wirklich das
entscheidende Kriterium
wir haben jetzt mit dem mit den
Eckpunkten eben Klarheit geschaffen wie
Einwanderung in unseren Arbeitsmarkt wie
fachkräftezuwanderung geschehen kann das
war in der Vergangenheit sehr begrenzt
und das war falsch wenn wir jetzt
darüber sprechen dass wir
fachkräftezuwanderung in der Breite
brauchen dann geht es natürlich auch
darum dass Menschen die schon eine
bestimmte Erfahrung haben ein
Berufsabschluss in ihrem Land schon
erworben haben den man sich dann hier
anerkennen lassen kann dass wir dass wir
das erleichtern weil wir eben diese
Person brauchen wir haben die offenen
Stellen aber da haben Menschen die
kommen schon eine Erfahrung und genauso
in der dritten Säule in der
potenzialsäure in Säule nicht sollen
Säule mit dem Punktesystem in dem es
darum geht welche Kompetenzen bringe ich
mit um in einem Land dann auch
arbeitsarbeit zu finden insofern ist es
ganz gewiss eine eine Integration in den
Arbeitsmarkt wir setzen sogar noch einen
Anreiz auch die Berufe anerkennen
verlassen indem die Menschen die das tun
weil wir wollen sie ja langfristig auch
im Arbeitsmarkt halten diese Anerkennung
hier auch nachholen und dann auch
schneller hier auch den Aufenthalt
genehmigt bekommen weil sie eben die
Anerkennung durchlaufen haben insofern
ist es ein wichtiger Schritt auch
Klarheit zu schaffen welche
Möglichkeiten es gibt bei uns Arbeit zu
finden und mit unserer Zukunft unseres
Landes zu gestalten
bevor wir jetzt weiter fortfahren
erläutere ich noch einmal was die
Präsidentin vor mir vorhin schon
angekündigt hat ich verlängere also
jetzt die Befragung um 15 Minuten das
heißt eine Minute haben wir davon schon
aufgebraucht von der Verlängerung es
gibt jetzt noch zwei Nachfragen zur
Ursprungsfrage und dann gehen wir weiter
in die angemeldeten Frage Fragen und ich
bitte darum wirklich die Fragen und
Antwortzeiten einzuhalten dann könnte es
uns gelingen in der Verlängerung
wirklich jeder Fraktionen auch dazu zu
helfen dass sie eine der angemeldeten
Fragen nicht nur stellen konnte sondern
es ist dazu auch Antworten und
Nachfragen noch gibt also ich bitte aber
auch auf das optische Signal zu achten
und dann wirklich das Fragezeichen zu
setzen oder den Punkt bei der Antwort
so die nächste Nachfrage stellt Frau Dr
Reinalter
frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte Frau
Ministerin zurück zum Fachkräftemangel
lange gewarnt lange ignoriert und
verschlafen heute Realität und in
Zukunft sicher eines der größten
innenpolitischen Probleme die wir zu
bewältigen haben wir sind gefährdet in
unserer Wirtschaft in unserem Wohlstand
in unserer Energiewende etc wir sind uns
einig das Bildung ein Schlüssel ist um
dem Fachkräftemangel zu begegnen und wir
sind uns auch einig dass wir mehr Master
und mehr Meister und mehr Meisterinnen
brauchen und was kann die Regierung tun
um die Gleichwertigkeit von akademischer
und beruflicher Bildung herzustellen
ja vielen Dank das ist ein Thema das uns
in der Breite beschäftigt war es
vielleicht vor 30 Jahren so dass das
Pendel auf der einen Seite war dass man
zu wenige
sich für die akademische Ausbildung
entschieden haben ist es jetzt leider
andersherum und das heißt wir müssen ein
Umdenken auch mit das heißt dass wir
alle auch die Verantwortung tragen auch
immer wieder darauf hinweisen und mit
denen das das Umdenken befördern dass
eben unsere berufliche Ausbildung
wirklich exzellentes es gibt ja auch
Artikel und Studien dass die
einkommensschancen hinterher höher sind
als vielleicht im akademischen Bereich
aber es geht ja um den Stellenwert in
unserer Gesellschaft und deswegen mit
der Exzellenzinitiative für berufliche
Bildung die ein Teil der
fachkräftestrategie sein wird diesen
Stellenwert auch noch mal herauszuheben
und den Respekt vor den Menschen die
nämlich dafür da sind dass wir in
Häusern wohnen können und dass unsere
Autos auch noch fahren diesen Respekt zu
zeigen diese exclanitiative einzelne
Talentes fördern gleichzeitig auch
Ausbildungsstätten und Mobilität und in
den Schulen dafür zu werben ich habe
schon gesagt Berufsorientierung ist
essentiell dafür und jetzt muss ich
leider aufhören es geht noch viel
es gibt noch hier eine Nachfrage nämlich
an genau eine Nachfrage 2021 würde im
Handel und Industrie nur jeder dritte
Ausbildungsvertrag von Frauen
geschlossen im Handwerk saß noch
schlechter aus der Wahnsinn nur jeder
weiß nur jeder Fünfte Ausbildungsvertrag
was tut die Bundesregierung dafür die
Frauen Ausbildungsquote in diesen
Bereichen und auch die Frauen
Erwerbsquote zu erhöhen also ich durfte
neulich bei einer Meisterfeier dabei
sein und es wurden 155 Meisterbriefe an
Jugendmeister und Meisterin überreicht
und es waren leider tolle Menschen aber
leider viel zu wenig Frauen dabei und
deswegen müssen wir früh anfangen wir
tun das indem wir die mint-bildung
Stärken weil natürlich viele
Ausbildungsberufe auch etwas damit zu
tun haben mit Mathematik aber auch mit
technischen und mit mit Dingen die eben
auch mit Physik was zu tun haben also
insofern die Mint Bildung Stärken
frühkindliche Bildung mit dem Haus der
kleinen Forscher in den Schulen die
außerschulische lernen Orte die Schulen
für eben die die Gesellschaft um sie
herum und des Gewerbe um sie herum und
die Berufsorientierung und die Frauen
die Männer mögen es mir jetzt verzeihen
aber das sagen die Studien man zahlt man
sieht dass Frauen sehr
also ein einen Willen haben etwas zu
verbessern und deswegen auch immer
wieder zeigen mit dem was ihr dort macht
in diesen tollen Berufen helft ihr
wirklich ein Stück weit die Probleme zu
lösen also die Wertstellung und auch die
tolle Möglichkeiten darzustellen
die nächsten Nachfrage stellt die
Kolleginnen dafür
vielen Dank sie haben gerade noch mal
darauf hingewiesen wie wichtig ihnen die
Gleichwertigkeit von akademischer und
beruflicher Bildung ist das ist ein
Thema das uns immer schon ein ganz
großes Anliegen war deswegen an der
Stelle die Nachfrage sie planen gerade
einen 200 Euro Zuschuss für Studenten
und Fachschüler auszubezahlen nicht aber
davon profitieren wie wir hören sollen
Vollzeitschüler auf Meisterschulen wo
ist hier die Gleichwertigkeit
ja sehr geehrte Frau Staffler die Frage
der Einmalzahlung an Studierende und
Fachschülerinnen und Fachschüler das
überhaupt Fachschülerinnen Fachschüler
in einer
Vollzeitausbildung Schulgang
berücksichtigt sind ist etwas was es
bisher auch noch nicht gab und das ist
etwas was wir uns auch gesagt haben dass
wenn der ganzen Breite das auch
ermöglichen es ist ja so dass es nicht
das einzige entlastungsinstrument ist
dass wir haben es gibt ja auch noch
natürlich aber das haben sie nicht
angesprochen es gibt aber auch die
Einmalzahlungen für diejenigen die eine
die einen Arbeitsvertrag haben oder ein
Minijob haben insofern eine ganze
Bandbreite an Fördermaßnahmen jenseits
dessen dass jetzt natürlich auch
gaspreisbremse und andere Thematik
entlastungspakete auf den Weg gebracht
werden
so viel meine Damen und Herren von der
Befragung der Bundesregierung mit der
Bundesministerin für Bildung und
Forschung wir melden uns nach 15 Uhr
wahrscheinlich gleich nach 15 Uhr wieder
mit einer aktuellen Stunde hier im
Deutschen Bundestag da dürfte es
mutmaßlich noch lebendiger werden da
geht es nämlich um die Proteste in China
und die deutsche China Politik eine eine
Aktuelle Stunde die auf Antrag der
Koalitionsfraktionen hier zustande kommt
und sie wissen alle wie intensiv über
dieses Feld insgesamt in diesen Zeiten
und in diesen Tagen diskutiert wird dann
sind wir wieder da einsweilen gehen wir
mal zurück aus dem Bundestag zu Hans
Werner Fittkau in unserem Bonner Studio
ja vielen Dank er hat schärfer in die
Hauptstadt und damit herzlich willkommen
liebe Zuschauer aus dem Bonner Phoenix
Studio an diesem Mittwochnachmittag das
kann richtig ungemütlich werden für
Viktor Orban denn die EU-Kommission
macht nun ernst und friert Milliarden
Summen ein der Grund die Regierung in
Budapest verstößt nach Einschätzung der
Kommission gegen Grundsätze der
Rechtsstaatlichkeit und geht nicht
entschlossen genug gegen Korruption vor
die Summen um die es geht sind wahrlich